straight up like in my gym shorts what
if i rolled up here you know what i mean
it would be okay because the way your
woman looked today i mean my god you
came with the damn goddess there you go
well then i should probably wear my
shorts next time i'd wear my draws or
whatever it takes to match that um
i want to ask you you know you made this
during covet it had to be hard but you
still come out with this movie that has
a great ensemble how did you guys vibe
like that or was it just that you know
there was you get lucky like you really
can't
it's so much of of any collaborative
effort right just depends on all the
people and you just have to go you can't
make people be who you want them to be
you just have to hope that they're not
only talented but really good people at
that that want to work together and get
the best out of everybody and that
starts from the top you know george sets
this tone with everyone that's really
it's clear like hey we're here to work
we respect each other we're going to do
a job everybody's going to be
professional it's just
it just goes all the way down to
everybody on there so it's really i
credit george with that that's something
that i've tried to do and it just
reminded me of how important is as a
director to set that set that tone big
birthday today lupe's birthday lupe's
right you really keep track of things i
do i'm on top of it are you celebrating
tonight what are you what are you doing
special because i know y'all like to
hang out
uh tonight i'm at the premiere of
thunderbar no i know that but i'm saying
it afterwards celebrating naturally we
have a little cocktail party i hope
you'll come i mean uh
after partying here
yeah unless you have another hike
in a mountain up there
you're active i appreciate that but you
don't need to advertise it you know you
don't need to sell it don't let
everybody know see let them discover it
you know i mean don't push it because
they'll they'll be more it'll be more
authentic if it just seems casual i feel
that i feel that
being a former sports guy and the last
question all the memes from the
basketball game hot
there were lots of them i'm a i am a
sports guy i'm a big meme guy i don't i
don't follow the memes with my kids like
the memes my kids my kids feel that the
highest form of um
success in life is to become a meme so
in that sense they have to be proud of
me uh despite uh powered appearances and
uh uh
you know
if i got in the business of commenting
on all the memes on the internet it
would force me to be witty and i just
can't i just don't have that to bring to
it so i'm just going to let it speak for
itself dude you got the face and the
hair it's all good you're good